okay dinosaur fans
experts have just uncovered the remains
of a gigantic dinosaur in argentina and
believe it could be one of the largest
creatures to have
ever walked the earth the mesozoic era
was about 252
to 66 million years ago and this was the
time of the really
big dinosaur but few measure up to what
are called titanosaurs the titanosaurus
belonged to a group of sauropod
dinosaurs which are defined by their
long neck and tail
and four legs now early in their
evolution sauropods were about the size
of dogs and
omnivorous but eventually they became
herbivores and
unbelievably huge now a team of south
american paleontologists
have unearthed the fossilized remains of
a massive
98 million year old titanosaur in
northwest patagonia in argentina and
this might be the largest dinosaur
specimen
ever found the fossils were extracted
from a dense sedimentary deposit known
as the candelaris formation and the
fossils excavated are believed to be
larger than that of all
previously discovered mega relatives
like the patago titan
the patago titan was found in the desert
near la fletche in 2008
it lived about 100 million years ago and
measured up to 37
meters or 122 feet long another
titanosaur found in southwestern
argentina in 1987
was officially titled argentinosaurus
and that one
grew up to over 40 meters or 131 feet
long and weighed more than 110 tons
that's about the weight of an adult blue
whale
and bigger than a 10 story building
you're gonna need a bigger boat
titanosaur remains are not unique to
south america although they are killing
it lately bones have been found on every
continent except
antarctica but this latest finding could
be a world record breaker so in order to
determine a more precise measurement of
the titanosaurus size
scientists still have to dig into its
evolutionary history but preliminary
data shows that it's most likely larger
than patagotite majoram and probably
will break the record as the biggest
animal
ever to walk the earth that's your story
time is up
like and subscribe for more